hi everyone thanks for coming for the
talk and especially elias forget ending
you can think of this start this talk as
talking from where he left
so this is joining to work with my lab
mix
along
imagine an oxford comma in between so
that will clear the camera
okay
so before i go to my talk let's recap
some of the talks which were in similar
ring spirit for this talk
so we have a lot of talks on discrete
distributions
for example yesterday sugeep talked
about escape making f divergences
jian kawak talked about ski making
entropy you hang talked about ski making
your support
uh sk i mean two days by jager and today
uh greg talked about testing about these
distributions
i guess some more to come
tomorrow um
the focus of all these stocks was to get
near sample optimal estimators for the
problems which we are studying for
example i think many of them were able
to solve this problem up to constants so
we know the sample complexity of most of
these up to kong skins now
i think a natural question which many of
you thought and some of you asked
including professor wiseman was what
happened to
what happens if we move from discrete to
continuous
and if we move from
let's say one dimension to high
dimensions
uh helios talked about continuous
and in this talk we are going to see how
dimensionality affects all these um
even the basic problems such as just
estimation
okay
okay let me ask you a very simple
question what's the most important
distribution
yes some people prefer you know lyft
kanga girls but yeah anyway
okay
we all know exaction
so let's see let's just familiarize
ourselves with some location i'm going
to use mu to denote the mean sigma to
denote the standard deviation and d to
denote the number of dimensions
and as some of you might have noticed
i'm going to use the covariance matrix
of the form sigma square times an
identity
uh this is mostly because we create
analyzing a most general setting and
finally if we figured out uh even this
basic problem is not well understood
so what's learning
what's learning a gaussian we get
samples from it
and we just want to estimate the mean
and the variance
um
let's be slightly more specific
we want to estimate the mean to some
accuracy and the standard deviation to
some accuracy and i'm multiplying
epsilon with some standard deviation to
get like a scanner answer
and uh all the results in this talk will
be with high probability and i'm not
going to discuss however
however epsilon delta will affect the
sample bonds
okay
and i'll ask the same question which
everyone else asked in the previous
talks uh how many samples we need i'll
get efficient algorithms
okay
this is
fairly strike forward it's just like if
you just take a prank and paper work it
out you'll figure out the number of
samples you need is b by epsilon square
where d is the number of dimensions and
epsilon is the accuracy you want
okay
so
and it's also information critically
optimal
and what's the efficient algorithm it's
just you find the empirical mean
empirical variance and you're done
okay so let's go to the next most
important distribution
and any gives us what that might be
okay
so what's a mixture you just take a
vacation of several components for
example here you have
uh two gaussian black and a green you
take the average and you get direct one
so now we had means for each of the
gaussian angular variance for each one
of them on top of it we have the weights
and i'm going to use k to denote the
total number of components
so it's used in practice because uh if
you have if you're whatever phenomena
you're observing has many modes this can
be used to capture it
and in theory we know that if you take a
lot of components you can approximate
any continuous distribution
so it can be used to model sub
populations for example if you have
heights of every guy in berkeley it's a
gaussian hikes of every woman in
berkeley it follows a gaussian and if
you look at the overall distribution
hikes of everyone in berkeley that
follows a gaussian mixture
so it's used a lot
and what's learning here
you again get samples
now you want to estimate each wake each
mean and each standard deviation to some
accuracy
and we can ask the same question sample
complexity efficient algorithms
okay
yeah what is the rule of d here i mean
why isn't one sample isn't their id or
the components is it one sample
the means can be different
the mean is a vector the mean at each
calling it can be different yeah it's a
very valid point yeah
any other questions
are just like these separate
estimation problem
we'll come to it's a very very good
point yeah i think that's good i can
take away message of this stock if you
want to do something in d dimensions you
should not do it in each dimension
not sure
okay
except but that's a very valid point
yeah
okay
it turns out well the previous
page previous sorry previous slide was
just like a back of the envelope
calculation this is an active area for
the last 20 odd years
so most of the previous results sorry
many of the previous results
uh they considered a general covariance
matrix
and we'll see how it affects your sample
complexity
so the work was targeted by a seminal
work by gas gupta who started with
gaussian mixtures when their components
are far
to be succinct like it looks something
like this
like you can clearly see that there are
two gaussian components
and he shortcut you can cluster again
into two groups and you can study each
one separately in other words you can
learn each one individually
and there was a lying off work
i'm not going to cite every i mean i
have a not psychic everyone here who
reduced the separation from square root
d to something of order of log d
over a course of like 20 odd papers
and in the most uh recent papers by uh
uh greg kalai and ankur moyka and ganga
sect of papers by belkin and singha they
were able to study this problem without
any separation so the gaussian mixtures
instead of looking like in the first
picture
even though they look like uh even
though if they look like second one they
can skill level to solve it
however
the shorter you can learn you can poly
with polynomial number of dimensions the
accuracy you want and a minimum wake
okay
and it's a very nice theoretical result
but they also showed a congress which
sure that
if
the number of components increases all
your answers scale exponentially in k
but
but the reason i'm saying it's a
theoretical result is because even for k
equals 2 is a very high degree
polynomial
um
it's like i don't think you optimize the
numbers but suffice to say like it's
like d cookie 500 or something
okay
are you laying off work is by daniel shu
sham kakade and gangema
uh who looked at spherical gaussians but
they made a very the parameters get
results in terms of a very clever
quantity which is like the k
largest eigen value
of like a covariance matrix
and they were able to show that you can
learn it in a polynomial in d which is
the number of dimensions k number of
components and also now you also
inversely depends on this eigenvalue
okay
it's difficult to exactly say what scale
polynomial is i tried doing a
computation i think it's roughly like d
cube or g 34
okay
uh if your information your first
question your last case is optimal
and uh i can tell you d 500 probably is
not the optimal answer
um
but even more interesting question is
argus assumptions necessary like even
these papers they need some mild
assumptions that their components need
to be far apart
so this assumption is really necessary
do you need to parametrize in terms of
the cake largest eigen value
but if you think about it for a while
you realize like do we really need to
estimate the parameters also
it's got an even more basic problem
which we are missing out
so this comes as to like a very
philosophical question
uh
by some u.s secretary of state during
world war
ah so his logic was if something looks
like a guck swims like a guck quacks
like a guck probably i'm going to think
of it as a duck
okay
uh i think a more appropriate answer for
this car could be if something looks
almost like a guck swims almost like a
guck
and does everything almost like a guck
gang do i really care whether it's a
duck or not
okay
so
philosophy
and this gets given notion of learning
which you can think of it as gangster
exclamation it's what elias taught in
the last talk
so you want to learn your mixture
you again want to learn means you again
want to learn the scanner deviation and
the weights
but
you don't really want to give guarantees
in terms of individual components
what you want to guarantee is that your
output mixture should be close to the
underlying one in some discounts measure
and i'm using l1 because it um
it captures the sample complex capacity
well first
and the idea is that if two mixtures
look alike
but somehow the parameters are extremely
different again possibly we cannot do
anything and no one also can do
something about it
if you think about from application
perspective
for many
problems this is enough for example if
you want to generate new samples all you
care about is learning a mixture which
looks like whatever training data you
had
or if you want to use
like learning a model class
use it for classification all you want
is your gaussian mixture to be close to
the underlying finger harmony
okay so you got some applications but
i'm not saying your parameter learning
is not important like if i ask you what
hike like if i give you a mixture get up
from everyone from berkeley like a hike
of people and i ask you what's the
average like hike of men you cannot say
oh i'll tell you an answer but i i can
only tell you up to some identifiability
issue it's not really a valid acceptable
answer
so really important if you want to
interpret your data
but
what
we know and organize have shown is
parameter learning can be thought of as
a combination of learning the way i
described plus an identifiability result
which states that if two mixtures are
close their components are close if two
mixtures are far apart their components
are far apart
okay
and we show that if you use our
algorithm and use the identifiability
results for previous papers you get
backup algorithms for pachmeter
estimation itself
okay
so same question watch the sample
complex key or get efficient algorithms
any questions
about the problem set up
okay of course
okay so i have only one very very
important slide that's this one so
and it may change over time but
the important thing is
it's not
good to go
okay so just to recap we get samples
from a mixture you want to learn your
means your variances anger weights
you want to output something which is
epsilon close to the angular 1
and there are no assumptions on this
problem apart
and it's exactly the way as i expected
here
okay so the algorithms we have one for
one dimensional algorithm or low
dimensional it's very cute it's
combinatorial
um
easy to explain which i'm going to do in
this talk
gaga1 is a high dimensional one
essentially works relies on pca but
there's a lot more techniques involved
and i'm just going to give you an
outline
and get to i'll give an outline for the
motivation for our algorithm
okay
so here are our results
uh in terms of sample complexity the
previous results need a d to the k
number of samples
you recollect uh k was the number of
components d was the number of
dimensions and
we have reduced gig from b to dk to d
log square d times some polynomial in k
and
in terms of computational complexity
our previous results need a d to the k
cube and we have reduced it to
d cube plus d times some exponential in
log d
one may say all these numbers are
exponential in k but for k small values
our algorithm has a runtime of d cube
well for the previous algorithm you get
something like d to be kq
okay any questions
yeah what's the dependency of the sample
complexity on k
okay i'll come to that so it's it's a
polynomial it's k2k9
and um
we don't know how to get music further
it's a very good question yeah
i will
now let me explain the one dimensional
case
so
so far uh let's try to
see how we can extend the algorithm
which we know for gaussians to gaussian
mixtures at least one guy mentioned
it turns out we tried we tried actually
making empirical meaning and empirical
variances
and
gut doesn't give you much because
imagine you have two gaussians which are
mixture with two components which are
really far apart if you estimate the
mean it will tell you zero if you tell
you if you look at the variance it will
tell you probably the discounts between
them but you will never give you the
exact
mixture which you are hoping for
and you can go for higher moments but we
couldn't prove a sample optimal
so i'm going to come up with a slightly
roundabout way of doing the same thing
okay it may look very
complicated when i explain it to you in
terms of gaussians but when i move to
the mixture you'll realize why i'm doing
it
okay
the idea is you want to quantize using
samples
so imagine you get a lot of samples like
say n for my mixture from a single
gaussian absorber there will be one
sample which will be close to the mean
and one which will be close to the mean
plus kind of deviation for example here
and all i'm saying is there'll be one in
this green region and one in this greek
region
believable
so you take n samples let's say n is of
order of one over epsilon and you
consider this set
n of x i comma x i minus x j square
okay this this set let's compute this
set has n times n minus 1 distributions
and what we know is one of the x i's
will be close to the mean one of the
values of x i minus x j will be close to
its kangaroo deviation
so therefore one of the distributions
will be epsilon close to the angle line
one
really neat
and you can show that uh if you're
running like a maximum likelihood on
this set
what we can but we don't get a maximum
likelihood we're having an elbowing
equivalent of it called chef a
estimator
and we were able to show that if your
number of samples is one over epsilon
square times log one over epsilon to
this chaffe esque maker
then you're obtaining gaussian which
which is epsilon close to the underlying
one okay
okay
so
total number of samples we are using is
whatever we have here plus one over
epsilon so the gamma acting term is
still 1 over epsilon squared
so this goes to mixtures very directly
um you're again taking samples from your
mixture you consider a set of all
possible gaussians all possible weights
you consider a set of all possible
mixtures where each gaussian belongs
using sag g and algebraics belong to the
sec w
and
similar analogy like before the sec
contains image which is epsilon close to
the underlying one
looks kind of like which doesn't do
anything special
is information critically optimal
it works irrespective of the wakes you
have
and you're running time what do you mean
by that my information theoretically
you can show that if you want to learn
like for example k equals two
um two component gaussian mixtures in
one dimension you need at least one over
epsilon square samples
previously used to take the cardinality
of your sec f square times one over
epsilon square we reduce g to epsilon to
the minus two times cardinality of f
which our problem if you calculate x
comes out to be epsilon three minus
seven
okay
so we have a polynomial time algorithm
which learns
the underlying gaussian mixture
information theoretically optimal pretty
simple yeah
it seems like this should also be
reasonably robust to
the tail
of the distribution isn't it because
like what if it wasn't a mixture like it
was a mixture of two lucky concave
distributions or something and you did
this did you get something same
um the point is i'm using the fact that
it's a parametric family
using the proofs i'm using the fact that
estimating a mean and just kangaroo
deviation is sufficient
so if you have something else parameter
any exponential family it will have the
same property so what was your question
about using the surface
you know i bought uh i think this whole
approach
um it turns out around the same time as
our work uh g and uh kong's counting was
kaskalakis at mit they were looking at
the same problem
and they have an algorithm which is
very similar to what i described to you
right now there are some minor
differences but we both use this chef
estimator we both realized that you need
to speed up the chaffe and so on
um and recently they have improved this
exponent from seven to five by using the
fact that you can use
the moment to reduce your search space
in term in f
okay
and as i said before
the result is not what surprises the
results is the algorithm works
irrespective of your wakes and variances
and
yeah that's it
okay now let's look at uh d-dimensional
mixtures
so i'm just going to motivate my
algorithm
and i'll address what i wanna ask
um why can't we learn every dimension
individually and just somehow patch them
together
it turns out it doesn't work the main
reason is when you are learning every
comp every recording egg by calling it
you want your status quick to converge
very well in every coordinate
so you need a lot of samples and
therefore you'll easily lose some
polynomial in the number of samples
but um we still want to use the lower
dimensional result because that's the
only tool we have learned so far
so what we do is we reduce the dimension
from b to k
y k because we know that k means they
occupy almost a k dimensional subspace
so we somehow project to that
and you solve it in k dimension and you
go back to d dimensions
um well this is known before like
algorithms which use this
our main contribution is to show that
you need to do one couple of rounds of
clustering before you do your projection
and this will be what
i was planning to talking rest of the
talk
um
and uh
just showing that these three steps
work
if you combine them very well
and it gives you near optimal sample
complex key i don't think we have a very
good understanding why it happens
uh but this is like the most motivation
i have for our algorithm
um let's speed it up a bit
um
okay so i said we do a low dimensional
projection the way we do it is you just
compute the covariance matrix and you
project it according to the top key
eigenvectors of it
and uh here is where uh more of the
random matrix theory comes into play
and the reason is it turns out s does
not converge to its expected value value
as fast as you want it to be in the case
of a mixture in case of a gaussian it
converges really fast when it's a
mixture it doesn't
uh the main reason is very simple um
okay
let's say you look at even one
dimensional case so
you don't have to worry about
the actual projection let's say you're
computing some compu uh quantity like
mu1 plus mu2 you just want to find the
average
okay what you do is you take this lot of
samples and you hope that the actual
average converges to the
empirical average converges to the
actual average it turns out error
depends on how far the gaussians are
separating
in other words
you need more samples if they are very
well separated this is kind of
counterintuitive because you think that
if the gaussians are far apart it's an
easy problem
and the reason and you're right it's
easy the reason is you want to cluster
first and then you want to estimate
within each cluster the idea is once you
cluster the variance within each cluster
would be small and then you can apply
the projection method which i described
to you before
gets our outline uh we first somehow
escalate the variance i won't go into
that and then we recursively cluster we
find a span of means we project account
to the span of the means
and we apply our load i mean whatever i
describe doing one dimensional algorithm
here
um as i said we make no assumptions on
weights and variances and that's the
tricky part to show that this
combination works especially your
clustering one
angle angx optimal
and
someone asked depending on k
so our sample complex case d k 2 g 9 log
square d by epsilon 3 4
and the information technically you can
show that the best thing you can achieve
is dk by epsilon square
and the best known result previously was
something of garda of d to dk
so we have reduced the exponential
depends on k to something polynomial
terms of time as a psychics reflect dq
uh from the previous
d to the k cube results
we use this clustering algorithm to
ensure that you subdivide the problem
into smaller problems
within each problem your means are close
by and the variances are well behaved
and even the weights yeah
so last slide oh yeah okay
so there were some recycled results on
identifiability by
maurice hart and eric price
uh geshorg if you want to learn
parameters to an accuracy epsilon
parameter again you need to pack learn
to act i mean one of the ways of scaking
your result is to say that you need to
pack learn to an accuracy epsilon
so you just plug it into our estimator
you get say you get a sample complexity
of d by epsilon to be 24
and the previous results give off a
general covariance matrix but they use
like d to get 30.
okay and this is to the best of my
knowledge the best known algorithm
without many assumptions
okay to conclude uh
um we looked at near optimal sample
schematics for mixtures of gaussians
are we sure to get a combinatorial
algorithm works for one dimension and a
spectral one for height and we didn't
show it but okay um
we have some extensions to axis align
gaussians
but we do not know how to solve it for
general gaussians
and more than that the problems which i
described all the topics i covered was
just for learning you can think of other
problems like clustering or regression
and only very recently people have
started looking at what's the
information critically the best way to
solve these problems so a lot of open
problems in this area
thanks
all right uh
maybe one question
uh and then the rest will
answer questions
because i can see in the actual mixture
model why it'd be helpful to
do all the components because we're
mixing
yeah
even in the case where you didn't have
one gaussian distribution
linearly
if the covariance matrix is uh if the
covariance matrix is diagonal yes
because you are estimating um
one number of variances which is like d
parameters
and number of means which are again d
parameters so you have totally 2d
parameters you can show that for this
case of the order of these samples
suffice
for you as a sample
a vector
sorry okay
yes number of information you get is n
times d number of samples times g
oh we can so whatever you get is
actually
d
yeah squared right the reason is you're
looking at clicking you clearly if you
want each component to concentrate well
if let's say you want each component to
concentrate epsilon accuracy you're
right one over epsilon squaring each
coding x suffice but you want the
euclidean skins to suffice yeah